on parle du jeune public après oui voilà
du jeune public puisque le cinéma les
yeux des à saint cyr l'école organise
depuis aujourd'hui ça a démarré
aujourd'hui jusqu'au 16 juin donc un
festival jeune public mais alors de quoi
s'agit-il
c'est un festival qui a pour but de
proposer des films aux enfants dès le
plus jeune âge et à leur famille
évidemment à leur entourage qui viennent
souvent au cinéma avec évidemment chez
les enfants ont du mal à venir tout seul
c'est sûr alors jeune public c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait penser jeunes enfants
enfin le montage à peu près entre 5 et
10 là c'est pas forcément le cas non
c'est pas forcément le cas on essaie de
déborder de dépasser des marges
on propose des choses qui sont adaptés
des trois ans il y avait des programmes
qui font moins d'une heure des tout
petits films qui sont tout à fait
adaptées et puis on essaie de déborder
aussi sur les plus âgées les familles
puisqu'on a aussi des des block busters
qui ont maintenant 20 ans comme jurassic
park ou bien plus comme fantomatique
valait pas tout on va on va y venir
alors déjà comment vous et vous est
venue cette idée de démonter ce festival
eux belle idée c c'est ça vienne d'eux
chose c'est d'une part le fait qu'ils
n'avaient pas de festival de cinéma dans
les yvelines alors il s'agit pas non
plus du festival de cannes s'est on a
encore une toute petite échelle mais
c'était un pur important quelque chose
et non sim cinématographique pour le
jeune public en tout cas en tout cas
pour le jeune public il y avait rien et
et puis la drac souhaitait soutenir ce
genre de la direction régionale des
affaires culturelles donc souhaité
soutenir ce genre d'initiative la ville
était complètement partant ça
correspondait à un long travail depuis
plusieurs années aux vers le jeune
public et puis
et puis voilà en fait je crois que j'ai
plus de la réponse convient oui ça va
c'est bon voilà c'est ça alors donc ce
festival vous l'avez que démarrer
l'année dernière c'était une première
ébauche
cette année
une programmation très riche alors
justement comment comment ça va se
dérouler alors ça y est je vous coupe
mais votre idée c'était que vous avez
une idée bien précise c'était travailler
sur trois axes oui ça en fait c'était de
évidemment de proposer des films des
projections d'essayer de refaire faire
revenir des films qu'on a vu il ya
longtemps il ya moins longtemps mais en
tout cas de voilà de remettre en valeur
billets ouais plus ou moins pas tant que
ça puisqu'il ya le monde de nemo par
exemple mais qui est donc pas si oublier
que ça m'écoeure peut-être ouais ouais
ouais j'en ai pas parlé évidemment
alors votre coup de coeur mon coup de
coeur cellules géantes mon coup de coeur
c'est le géant de fer c1 c'est un film
de brad bird qui a aussi réalisé les
indestructibles mission impossible et ce
genre de choses et qui sont son tout
premier film c'est un dessin animé qui
était qui est l'adaptation d'un roman
américain qui est un grand succès aux
états unis complètement inconnu en
france évidemment et qui raconte
l'histoire de l'amitié entre un jeune
enfin jeune garçon est un robot qui
arrive de l'espace dont de 16 ou et donc
on va se rendre compte qu il enfin voilà
qui est tout à fait amicale en tout cas
avec cet enfant mais dont on se rend
compte qu'il est conçu comme pour être
une arme alors pour ceux qui savent ne
dit rien du tout par exemple on va
regarder la bande annonce exactement
vers
les centres match
d
m
non
courroye
mieux les tuer
ce format
chien
soit
alors bertrand là ce géant de fer s'est
tue un film en version sous-titrée
originale version sous titrée alors la
bande annonce en version originale
sous-titrée le film est en version
française celui qu'on a adapté à tous
les publics est complètement mener des
enfants qui l'ont vu aujourd'hui qu'il y
avait 5 ans qui ont adoré qui sont
sortis en sautant dans tous les sens
parce que on rappelle ce a démarré
aujourd'hui ça a démarré aujourd'hui
ouais pareil petit retour vous pouvez
nous nous faire justement de cette
première après-midi à ben enfin les
enfants étaient vraiment heureux en
sortant l'important pour nous c'était
aussi pour cette ouverture de mettre en
valeur le travail le travail dès qu'on a
fait avec un groupe d'enfants d'un
centre de loisirs à le centre de loisirs
romain rolland qui sont qui sont venus
pendant toute l'année voir des films
avec nous en discuter avec nous en faire
des ateliers des réalisations justement
votre un autre c'est l'une des choses à
mettre en lumière exact travail scolaire
dans la ville mais c'est de là que vient
le festival le l'idée était de mettre en
valeur le travail qui est fait dans la
ville depuis des années et on travaille
alors l'année dernière on a travaillé
avec lycéens et les écoliers à cette
année on a réussi à travailler en plus
avec des collégiens les collégiens du
lit du collège jean racine on travaille
avec des lycéens du lycée mansart on
travaille avec les écoliers de l'école
jean jaurès chacun d'eux va venir animer
une soirée on leur donne soit des cartes
blanches ou choisissent un film et ils
viennent de présenter les lycéens c'est
un peu particulier parce qu'ils ont
réalisé des courts métrages dans le
cadre d'un atelier avec leur téléphone
portable et donc qui viennent présenter
ses films d'ailleurs y aura une
compétition le soir de cette
présentation publique ah oui le bruit
qui est largement attendu pour venir
voter et élire le meilleur film ce
qu'ils ont intitulé le mais le miroir
d'or d'ailleurs y aller j'y vais vous
présenter le film qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
choisie il s'agit de duquel alors les
collégiens vont présenter le magicien
d'oz qui est le film qui a qui a tiré
leurs projets culturels pendant toute
l'année autour de la thématique du
voyage et de la fantasy et puis les
écoliers présenteront un film surprise
et familière banon
ces principes ben voilà et le et
aujourd'hui les enfants du centre de
loisirs ont présenté tout le travail
qu'ils ont fait des dons qui sont montés
sur scène face à tous les copains et
c'était pas facile et voilà c'était un
grand moment pour eux et pour nous
d'ailleurs parce que c'était émouvant
vraiment d'avoir travaillé pendant un an
avec eux et de les voir
finalisé leur projet comme ça c'était
très bon et alors vous avez également
dans cette programmation
donner quelques créneaux à dessiner
rencontre c'est par exemple
et si les comptes et puis un ciné
concert dessiné plein de choses tout ce
qu'on peut mettre avant ou après signer
on le fait donc il ya un ciné concert
sur des courts métrages de charlie
chaplin avec un accompagnateur au piano
en piano solo qui voit là dans la plus
grande tradition des dd du cinéma des
premiers temps finalement il y aura un
ciné conte avec berti soulier qui est
une conteuse qui avec qui on est habitué
de travailler et qui remplit les salles
et les coeurs chaque fois de bonheur ont
un ciné rencontre avec pascal diez sur
un documentaire autour de l'école et des
projets culturels à l'école et puis
une curiosité puisqu'on a fait appel à
un bruiteur de cinéma limbes routeur
professionnel matelly bruitages voilà
alain platiau qui viendra avec sa
compagne noël guichard et qui vont faire
découvrir le métier de bruiteur et faire
faire des bruitages au public pendant la
soirée alors on rappelle ça démarrait
aujourd'hui c'est jusqu'au 16 juin au
cinéma les yeux des visas de
saint-cyr-l'ecole bertrand vignes et
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci à vous
voir on reste encore dans cette
thématique du cinéma mais paraissant sur
l'école on parle clayes-sous-bois voilà
les clés sous bois où s'est tenue samedi
dernier le festival de courts métrages
dont le réalisateur mabrouk el mechri
qui est également parrain du festival
était au micro de julie rocha soirée
sont les côtes
pas de tapis rouge au festival les clés
du cinéma samedi mais un parrain
d'exception mabrouk el mechri
mabrouk el mechri c'est un réalisateur
qui a qui est né à versailles et qui a
vécu pendant 15 ans il me semble dans
cette ville
donc naturellement la procès mabrouk ce
quelqu'un qui connaît bien la vie qui
connaît les jeunes et c'est quelqu'un
qui est qui reconnurent le ménage et
c'est d'ailleurs aux clayes-sous-bois
que mabrouk el mechri a tourné ses
premiers courts métrages à la fin des
années 90 le court métrage
est un laboratoire c'est souvent
considérés comme l'antichambre du long
métrage mais je pense que sa spécificité
c'est un sprint alors que le long
métrage est une est un marathon donc
c'est pas la même préparation c'est au
tour généralement très très vite avec
peu de moyens et
avec beaucoup d'énergie le clae sien est
aujourd'hui mondialement réputé pour
avoir dirigé dans ses films jean claude
van damme ou encore bruce willis et
aussi pour la réalisation de la série
maison close diffusés sur canal+ fort de
son expérience il était président du
jury lors de cet après midi de
projection avec une vingtaine de films
en compétition d'avoir un retour sur le
travail c'est aussi pour ça qu'on fait
les festivals qu'on va dans les
festivals et donc voilà c'est un plaisir
d'avoir son avis pour cette deuxième
édition le prix du meilleur court
métrage a été attribué à bad boys tout
de daniel brunet et ses fûts schumi
postérité retiendra une poursuite ça
faisait longtemps
l'événement gratuit ponctué de
rencontres entre le grand public et les
réalisateurs a attiré près de 150
amateurs près de la bibliothèque des
mesures